have you ever wondered about the deepest  desire of scp-2337  or dr spenco foundation researchers used  scp-978 the desire camera to snap a  photo of dr spanko while he was eating a  plate of gummy worms in the center of  his enclosure and this was the result  inconclusive dr naismith who supervised  the test later remarked the presence of  a human face resembling that of welsh  musician tom jones it should be noted  that before the photo was able to fully  develop scp-230  grabbed it ripped it into pieces and  promptly ate those pieces when asked to  give an explanation he stated apollo  jones of mine flandola profound  embarrassing scrag know what newfangles  are pussycats to be this one no jose  he is an interesting character isn't he